throughout this week we've been hearing
messages
from Pastor Randy ski um and we know a
lot of you also have questions based on
topics um that he's touched on and
perhaps topics that you are awaiting
some insight on um so I'd invite Pastor
ski up
for um and to start off we've had a
request which I'm sure all of you would
join me in asking as well um and that
yeah let's pray Our Father in Heaven
thank you for preserving us up to this
point thank you Father for the
protection of your angels the guidance
of your spirit as we enter into this
question and answer session give us
simple give me simple wisdom dear God
that I may instruct your people a right
in Jesus name I pray amen amen now the
first request is for you to share your
conversion story well there's nothing
fancy to my conversion story I don't
have a date when anything catastrophic
happened I grew up in a very very
religious home my mother was a very
religious woman loved the Lord with all
her heart and soul and everything else
and so I just came up that way and at
some point I decided to give my life
entirely to God I don't remember when
but it is really a boring testimony I
wasn't a drug addict and I didn't fall
off the back of a truck or get blown up
in a war nothing of the kind just grew
up in a religious home decided to follow
God when I came to an awareness of who
he was and that's
it amen thank
you um and the next question uh this
person is asking how can I help my
friend who is confused by conflicting
Bible views from me and another
denomination without putting down the
other person's
faith we never try to put down other
people's faith we simply lift up the
truth that's all we do uh preaching
truth does not require undermining other
people the truth will do that all by
itself we cannot allow the feelings of
others to get in the way of the
Proclamation of Truth the simple fact is
truth offends the carnal nature it
really is offensive to the carnal nature
and that's one of the reasons Christ was
killed because he spoke the truth the
truth is a really dangerous thing to
speak even in churches because
unconverted members will get very very
angry with you and so what I recommend
your friend do is simply present the
truth compassionately quietly very
prayerfully so that the spirit of God
can move on that person's mind but the
truth must be presented in its Purity
even if it eventually causes hard
feelings uh sometimes a little pain is
necessary before he in comes about so
just tell your friend present the simple
truth and allow the Holy Spirit to do
the rest thank you mhm uh the next
question um is quite a popular question
um and it's if Adventists or saus
believing Believers um on the
Sabbath have a job that saves wherein
either healthc care or Emergency
Services should they be paid for it
where do we draw the line when it comes
to necessary work on the
Sabbath but Jesus says it's lawful to do
good on the Sabbath nor in the Bible are
we told it's lawful to work now if
you're a doctor or a nurse or that
related field where you're taking care
of people's
Health sickness must be dealt with on
the Sabbath Jesus healed on the Sabbath
you cannot allow someone to suffer and
say well I am a 7day Adventist no but if
you do
that uh relieving of suffering as a
nurse or a doctor whomever Ellen White
counsels Us in medical Ministry page 216
paragraph 2 the money you receive for
that should be given to the
church you're not to earn money on the
Sabbath we're not to make a living on
the Sabbath if you examine the miracle
of the manner in Exodus 16 no Mana fell
on the seventh day and the Mana was sent
to preserve their lives they were hungry
so the the man is a form of of Life
sustenance if you make a living on the
Sabbath it did not come from
God did you hear me if you make a living
on the Sabbath the day of rest it did
not come from God Amen now Satan can
give you things he wanted to give Christ
all the kingdom of the world he said
they mind to give if you are required to
come
on a Sabbath as a medical professional
your patients ought to know you are a
seventhday Adventist who observes the
sth day Sabbath you must do everything
possible not to go but if you have to go
to E suffering go whatever money is
given to you for that must be given to
the church because you do not work on
Sabbath you do good on Sabbath
mhm why do you look so
depressed
go thank you you you're
welcome by the way
sorry I don't know how it is in England
United States if you work in Saturday or
Sunday you get double or time and a half
that sort of it happens here and some
Adventists do that for that
reason time and a half God reads this
and he knows you're
wrong Christ object lessons page 316
paragraph 2 Every Act is judged by the
motive Every Act is judged by the motive
that prompts
it enough said on that go ahead sister
thank you um next question can probation
close for children and why what's that
can probation clo for children and
why very good
question when the two angels came to
Sodom to uh visit lot and God invited
them in men came to sodomize the Angels
Among them were little boys the Bible
tells us that both young and old came
either the young probably came to learn
but they
came young people can be very very
vicious if you thought about babies
that's something else in United States
in large cities they gang sometimes the
qualification for gang might be to kill
somebody and the gangs some times send
little boys through the killing because
they know they won't spend much time in
prison and there are some well-known
young murderers and assassins in gangs
in the US young boys and girls can be
very very cruel now I don't have a Bible
verse that specifically says if there's
probation closing for young I do know
God closes probation when he sees that
all his wooing and his efforts to save a
person have come to know to know know no
fruit and he closes
probation um a a child's outcome may be
based on the life of the parents and the
other side a child's salvation be
connected to the life of the parent but
God closes probation as he sees
fit but the devil does not respect
childhood if demons could possess pigs
they can possess
children are you following me Sin is Sin
regardless of age God takes into
consideration your circumstances and the
level of knowledge you have but the fact
that 2 12 or 13 does not mean you are
secure against the closing of
probation but I have no specific text
regarding age the safest thing to do is
when God speaks to you listen Josiah was
eight when he was king of Israel Jesus
was 12 when he was discussing uh the the
law with the doctors in the temple
Paul said to Timothy and from a child
thou Hast known the holy scriptures
which are able to make thee wise under
salvation little children can know a lot
they can do a lot of good they can do a
lot of evil but the final decision rests
with
God if you have children raise them to
know
God please view their salvation as more
important than
yours yes thank you um the next question
is how can I take away fear how can you
take away fear 2 Timothy 1:7 For God
hath not given us the spirit of fear but
of power and of love and of the sound
mind fear disappears as Faith
grows faith in God is the antidote for
fear and faith grows in connection with
the word Romans 10:17 now Faith cometh
my hearing and hearing by the word of
God fear came in as a result of
Disobedience Genesis 2:25 and they were
both naked the man and his wife and were
not ashamed Genesis 3:7 and the eyes of
them both were open and they knew that
they were naked and they SED fig leaves
together and made themselves aprons
verse n and they heard the voice of the
Lord God Walking In The Garden in the
cool of the day and Adam that's verse 9
of Genesis 3 and Adam and his wife hid
themselves from the presence of the Lord
God amongst the Trees of the garden and
the Lord God called unto Adam and said
to him where is thou and he said I heard
thy voice in the garden and I was
afraid fear came in because of sin and
sin is Disobedience to God the the
remedy for that is trust in thus sayth
the
Lord are you with me if God said it
believe it why should you believe
believe it because he said let there be
light and there was light can you trust
that word yes faith in God removes fear
because fear does not come from God
unless you mean fear as awe and respect
but that's not what the question is
asking it means this Terror this dread
this uncertainty this worry this anxiety
all of that goes when we put our trust
in thus sayth the Lord and so the Bible
says bring you all the tithe into the
stor house that they may be meet in mine
house and prove me now herewith sayith
the Lord of hosts if I will not open you
the windows of heaven and pour you out a
blessing that there shall not be room
enough to receive it you believe that
and return the
tithe even though rent is due next week
and you're
unemployed return the tithe obey God and
see God work for you obedience gets rid
of
fear amen thank you um yes oh okay thank
you I'm going to invite Divine harmonies
to give us a special item and while they
are coming I just want to welcome in a
special way our friends who've come out
from the boundaries of cine Kobe and
Welling bra who have come to join us to
SE at Jesus feet and be fed feel at home
be at home this is our church when you
find yourself around here come to Kobe
church and worship with us
amen I don't know
sorry
[Music]
there is
welome for the
[Music]
S and more
graes for the good
good there is
Mercy with the
Savior there is
healing in his
blood but we make
his to
nrow by
foral of a heart
and we
magy
his with theal
he will
not there's a
wi in God's
Mery like the
wi of the
SE there a kindness
in his
jce which is more
than
[Music]
Liberty
if we take
he his way
and our lives will be more
loveing in our
Liv of the
Lord the
wi it
Mercy like the
wi of the
S than and kindness
is
jce which is more
than
Liberty there is kindness there is
winess there is Justice and Justice
there is
Mery wi
the there is good day God's goodness
there is
forgi forgiveness God's mercy
over
me there's a
wi in God's
mercy like the
wi of the
sea there's a
kindness in his
Justice which is more
than Liberty
is a
kindness in his
jce which is
more more than
[Music]
[Applause]
Lord how are they increased that trouble
me many are they that rise rise up
against me many there be which save my
soul there is no help for go for him in
God but thou oh Lord at a shield for me
my glory and the lifter up of my head I
Cried unto the Lord with my voice and he
heard me out of his Holy Hill I laid me
down and slept I awake for the Lord
sustained me
I will not be afraid of 10,000s of
people that have set themselves against
me
roundabout arise oh Lord save me oh my
God for thou H has smitten all my
enemies upon the cheekbone thou Hast
broken the teeth of the
ungodly salvation belongeth unto the
Lord thy blessing is upon thy
people God is
good and all the time
Psalm 100 verse5 for the Lord is good
his Mercy is
Everlasting and his truth endureth to
all generations have you ever felt that
you were all
alone friends have forsaken you family
have forsaken you if that ever happens
read Psalm 3 Lord how are they increase
that trouble me many are they that rise
ra up against me perhaps on the job in
the school because you're the only
Adventist in your family many there be
which save my soul there is no help for
him in God when people write you
off but thou oh Lord at a shield for me
my glory and the LIF her up of my head a
depressed person does not walk around
like this the person who walks like that
God says I am the one who lifts up your
head put your trust in
God believe God to be a personal God not
just an
idea a huge cloud in heaven a personal
God who cares about everything in your
life he even cares about a sparrow when
one dies he knows Jesus said you have
more value than many sparrows God is a
person who cares about you he wants the
best for you ultimately he wants you so
prepared to fellowship with him face to
face I said face to
face when Jesus spoke to zakus he said
the son of man is come to seek and to
save that which was
lost what was lost
fa to face communication with God what
was lost painless child birth what was
lost all animals tame what was lost you
name it a lot was lost and the gospel
reverses all of that can you say Amen it
reverses all of that but one of the
things we face and this is not my
message one of the things we face you
see we are so surrounded by sin it is
difficult to get the Christian to
believe there is a world coming where
everything will be
righteousness even Christians have a
difficulty believing God will set up a
righteous world and this is where he'll
Place those who have put their trust in
him and I want all of you
ready to be in that world no sin
no sickness no hospitals no
operations no
wheelchairs no psychotic
medication no divorce courts no juvenile
detention centers no spousal abuse wives
beating up their husbands No Such
Thing husbands doing the same no
delinquent children no boring preachers
no such thing a world where all is bliss
you're busy because God is a busy God he
gave adam work we will help God to
manage the entire universe and this
universe is vast let me say it again we
will help God to manage the universe
because the redeemed will take Satan's
Place Satan
Lucifer was the closest Angel to God in
the book The Faith I live by Father in
Heaven as I give these introductory
remarks be with me father in Jesus name
amen I won't do what happened Friday
night that was the holy spirit's work
the introductory remarks became the
sermon I don't think that'll happen
today Ellen White writes the fifth I
live by Page uh 1666 paragraph
2 God made him good and beautiful
meaning Lucifer as near as possible like
himself think of those
words Christ who is the creator of
everything he made
Lucifer he made him as much like
himself as he
could Lucifer came this close to being
God but you just can't make God are you
following me but he was the closest
thing you can come to actually being God
God made him good and beautiful as near
as possible like himself you get a
glimpse of that by looking at the high
priest he had uh 14 stones on his uh
breastplate 14 uh 16 43 no 12 and 13
13 if you read about Lucifer before he
fell Ezekiel 28 13 thou Hast been in
Eden the Garden of God every precious
stone was thy covering the sardius the
topaz the diamond the barel the onx the
Jasper the sapphire the emerald the
carbuncle and gold of the 13 stones on
the high priest who represents Christ
Lucifer had
10 are you with me so if you have Christ
decked out in his stones and you have
Lucifer you had to look closely to
figure out who's who he looked so much
like
Jesus
yet he
fell tremendous
fall God will replace the vacancy
created by his fall with the
redeemed the Bible teaches that if you
read
microscopically go to Colossians
3 you need to know where you're headed
if you follow
God Colossians 3 all of us at work we
desire promotion God is giving us a
promotion you can't get any higher than
that Colossians 3 we'll read from verse
one you have Colossians
3 from verse
one when you found it
amen if he then be risen with Christ do
what seek those things which are above
keep reading where Christ sth where on
the right hand of God now where is
Christ on the right hand of God keep
this in mind go to Ephesians 2
you have Ephesians 2 let's read from
verse four but God who is rich in Mercy
for his great love wherewith he loved us
even when we were dead in sins hath
quickness together with Christ by Grace
you saved and hath raised us up together
and made us do what sit together where
in Heavenly places where in Christ Jesus
now where according to Colossians 3 is
Christ sitting
now if you're in Heavenly places sitting
in Christ where are you sitting on the
right hand of
God and I heard one lonely
amen
ah what's the name of your prime
minister who you've had so many the past
two and a half years I have lost count
what's his
name spell it
who all right whatever his name
is God bless him if he invited you to
number 10 Downing
Street to
dinner you'd buy new
clothes take a
shower tell all your friends by
accident hire a cab not a cab a
limousine and go to Downing Street as
though you're MP
why you're dining with the Prime
Minister the Bible teaches we will sit
on the right hand of
God you turn there's God and there the
Angels over there ah you didn't get it
no angel sits at the right hand of
God in Christ that's where we said now
I'll never come back to this
place nobody talks to the preacher I
said in Christ that's where we sit
now thank
you ah my brothers and sisters this is
something to look forward to but right
now it has tremendous
benefits Let Me Explain If you
considered when you know the the the
Queen Elizabeth when she was alive she
was the most famous Monarch on earth
when people said the queen they didn't
think of the queen of Denmark or the
queen of North Korea they thought of the
Queen of England that's the queen
actually when she died my heart was very
heavy anyway if you were sitting next to
her wouldn't you watch your
behavior
yes
MH many many years ago I watched a
documentary not a documentary there was
some celebration in Scotland edingburg
castle and the queen was there perhaps
to celebrate something and an official
was walking with her and he accidentally
put his hand in his pocket when you walk
with the queen you do not put your hands
in your and the commentators were
shocked saying his hand is in his pocket
you do not put your hand in your pocket
when you're walking with the queen a few
years ago an American actress called
Angelina Jolie came to Buckingham Palace
to receive an award
and for the first time she was properly
covered are you with me her knees were
covered up here was covered armpits
covered she was covered why she was
coming into the presence of the queen
now I've told you in plain Corby English
through Christ you sit at the right hand
of God should that affect your behavior
yes
but you see we do not live by
faith because we can't see God he slips
our
mind when I was a little
boy if I was doing mischief and my
mother came around the corner I was
converted
immediately M immediately I stopped
that's my
mother I'm a married man
if my mother when she visited my home or
we went to see her there's some things I
wouldn't
do with sister SK are you with me that's
my mother sitting right
there so I behave like a single man
that's my mother are you following me
now God is your
father if you believe you are in Christ
on his right hand it changes your
behavior you don't sit at the right hand
of God and go to strip club
you don't sit at the right hand of God
and go to a nasty
website there's God right
there you don't sit next to God and
cheat on your exam do you believe you're
seated next to God in
Christ and so I say to you my brothers
and
sisters this God is coming
because right now we're seated through
faith in
Christ but that's not good enough let me
explain why listen to a passage of
scripture you know very well do not go
to it don't put it on the whatever that
is let not your heart be
troubled you believe in God believe also
in me in my father's house are many
mansions if it were not so I would have
told you let me PA on that I love that
about Christ he said if it were not so I
would have told you and as I always say
if I had changed the
Sabbath I would have told
you if I wanted you to
smoke I would have told
you if I wanted you to whatever I would
have told you if I didn't tell you don't
do
it I would have told I go to prepare a
place for you
notice he said in my father's house and
many mansions but he's the one doing the
preparation I go to prepare a place for
you and if I go and prepare a place for
you I will come again and receive you
unto myself that where I am there you
may be also now we'll recite that again
this time we're
stressing pronounce to see how personal
God is let not your heart be troubled
you believe in God believe also in me in
my father's house are many mansions if
it were not so I would have told H I go
to prepare a place for you and if I go
and prepare a place for you I will come
again and receive you unto myself that
where I am there ye may be also can you
say Amen Jesus wants you where he is you
see right now you cannot touch
Christ it has to be by faith but that's
not close
enough let me explain what I mean right
now Christ dwells with us through the
Holy
Spirit not himself literally because
he's still Flesh and Bones and Flesh and
Bones cannot be all over the place at
the same time it is a Divine quality on
the presence but Christ laid it aside as
part of the price of your
salvation you didn't understand what I
said my fault let me try again
a Divine being is omnipotent what does
that mean all powerful omniscient what
does that mean all knowing omnipresent
what does that mean can be everywhere at
the same time we can't explain that
Christ laid aside one of the three I
never said he lost
it I said he L Divinity can't lose its
quality he laid it aside because he has
kept his human form
do you realize Christ is still
human in heaven M listen to Paul in
first Timothy chapter 2:4 20 years after
Christ went
back chapter 2:5 for there's one God and
one mediator between God and man the man
Christ Jesus he's H the man Colossians
2:9 for in him dwelleth the fullness of
the godhead bodily
bodily Jesus Christ still has his human
nature which means you and I can touch
him the father is a spirit the Holy
Ghost is a spirit Jesus tells us in Luke
24 36-38 a spirit hath not Flesh and
Bones you can't grab a
spirit so we're not sure exactly how a
spirit exists but we know God is a
spirit and he has emotions he's happy
he's sad he's jealous he can get angry
he's longsuffering he's patient he's
forgiving tenderhearted he loves his
children all of that so however he
exists we know he has all these emotions
and he passed them to us in creation the
holy spirit is a spirit Jesus was
entirely Spirit but now he is flesh and
divine let me say it again Christ is
divine still God but this time his
divinity is still wrapped in
humanity when Christ comes back you and
I will be able to touch
him I don't know how you'll touch the
father he's a spirit when Christ rose
from the dead he appeared to the
disciples in Luke 24 from: 36 as they
thus spake Jesus himself stood in the
midst of them and said unto them peace
be unto you but they were terrified and
arried and supposed that they had seen
the spirit and he said unto them why are
you troubled and why do thoughts arise
in your heart behold my hands and my
feet that it is I myself in other words
look at the marks of the crucifixion
handle me and see he told them come and
grab
me when we get to heaven or the new
world we can grab him right now we grab
him by faith you understand me but
Christ wants to be where we are
personally
not represented by the spirit no
intermediary between Christ and his
beloved he wants to be with us
personally so he's coming back to
receive us unto himself he said that
where I
am which means right now we are not
where he is and he's not where we are
his presence is represented by the Holy
Ghost yes we thank God for that that's
how Christ dwells in Us by the Spirit
but his personal self is in
heaven still
human and God wants that Gap
eliminated when Christ comes you and I
will deal with him
physically you can touch him sit next to
him lean on his bosom as John the
disciple
leaned and all of us can lean the same
time there's always room in the bosom of
God these things we must think
about we cannot be so overcome by rent
and food and taxes that we forget a
better world is
coming let's examine the example of Our
Father Abraham go to Hebrews 11 let's
read from verse 8 let's look at the
example of Our Father Abraham and the
Bible says of Abraham like father like
son this my modern language but that's
the teaching of scripture in John
chapter 8 we must be like
Abraham Hebrews 11 from: 8 and may the
Lord put his words in my mouth by faith
Abraham when he was called to go out
into a place which he should after
receive for an inheritance obeyed and he
went out not knowing whether he went by
faith he SED in the land of promise as
in a strange country dwelling in
Tabernacle T Les with Isaac and Jacob
the HS with him of the same promise now
you read verse
10 for he looked for a city which hath
foundations whose Builder and maker is
God now are we to understand Abraham
walked around all day like
this is that what the text is saying
what does the text mean by he
looked his mind
was on that City to come notice two
opposites in the language look at verse
n by faith he soed in the land of
promise as in a strange country dwelling
in what Tabernacles did Abraham move
from place to place yes or no yes you
can do that with a
tabernacle
suggesting a nomadic life I am only here
temporarily but he
looked he
expected he
anticipated a city which ha
Foundation a tabernacle has no
Foundation that's why you can move it a
city has foundation and so our Father
Abraham he lived with a Consciousness
this is a temporary
Arrangement many of give us live in this
world as though we here for
eternity no time for God some time for
church no time for God like Abraham we
must look for a city which have
Foundation this is temporary keep
reading let's go to verse 13 of Hebrews
11 these all died in
faith let's pause on that for a minute
to die in faith is to die in obedience
are you with me someone who dies in
faith cannot be
lost these all died in faith what is
Faith a very foundational definition
holding on to the word of God believing
thus sayth the Lord these all died in
faith not having received the promises
but having seen them AAR off and were
persuaded of them mhm I believe I am
persuaded if I confess God forgives me
and
confessed finish verse 13 confess what
there were strangers and pilgrims on the
earth seventh day Adventists should live
that
way we are strangers on this Earth we
are p passing through and this is both
spiritual and
literal and so when we sing this world
is not my home we should sing it with
great seriousness they
confessed that they were strangers and
pilgrims on the earth and that
confession was surely seen by the
surrounding tribes their lifestyle was a
confession we don't
belong and my brothers and sister SS
listen to what Christ says about his
disciples in John
17:14 and verse 16 keep in mind that
Abraham Isaac Jacob and their wives they
confessed they were strangers and
pilgrims on the
earth listen to um what did I say John
17 let's read verse 14 let me know when
you have
it John is a lovely book take time and
read it lovely book written by the
disciple closest to Christ and the one
of whom El right says he most perfectly
reflected the character of Christ John
he lived longest he's the only one who
died the natural death of the 12
disciples you have John 17 verse1 14
read with me I have given them Thy word
and the world hath hated them why for
they are not of the world even as I am
not of the
world you talk about a standard Christ
prayed that prayer while he was was on
the earth he was on the Earth but not of
the earth we are in the flesh we must
not be of the
Flesh in other words we're human but we
don't live by human passions we follow
Divine leadings are you following me
they are not of this world verse 15 I
pray not that thou should take them out
of the world but that thou should keep
them from the evil 16 they are not of
the world even as I am not of the world
now with this in mind we listen to the
Patriarchs again they confessed that
we're strangers and pilgrims We Don't
Belong if this is the world listen to
what the Bible says about the world 1
John
5:19 and we know that we are of God and
the whole world lith in wickedness now
if the whole world lies in wickedness
you're child of God you're out of
place you didn't get it
if you're going to play a basketball
game at least United
States and you come with cleats to play
soccer you don't
belong you belong on a
pitch not a basketball court are you
with
me if you come to scuba dive and you're
wearing a suit you're out of place
you've come to preach not to
dive if we're children of God and this
world is a world of wickedness we are
out of place if we do not feel out of
place something is wrong with
us the Christian comfortable in the
world is in
trouble let me say it again the
Christian who's comfortable in this
world is in
trouble we must feel out of place in a
world dominated by
sin if the character of Christ Christ is
our aim our desire our goal we must feel
out of place in a world of sin
Revelation 12:9 and the Great Dragon was
cast out not old serpent called the
devil and Satan which deceiveth the
whole world he deceives the whole world
a world under satanic deception is not
our
home go to 2 Timothy chapter 4
2 Timothy 4: 7 and
8 do you have
that some of you still
searching we have a little
time do you have 2 Timothy 4:7 8 at
least I'm sure you know verse
seven read with me
I have fought a good fight I have
finished my course I have kept the faith
henceforth there's later for me what a
crown of righteousness which the Lord
the righteous judge shall when at that
day keep and not to me only come on but
unto that love is appearing
yes they're looking for it their love is
appearing they talk about it they live
for it they study for it they dress for
it un to them that love his appearing
one of the foundational teachings of
this church is the second coming of
Christ and it seems that this most of
the church are not getting ready most of
the church isn't getting ready for the
return of Christ and to and to those
that
love is
appearing they'll receive a crown of
life my brothers and
sisters I told you earlier we will take
the place of
Satan let me put it more
bluntly in the new world we will be
closer to God than
Angels we're closer to God than Angels
right
now and you say to me but angels are in
heaven or we're down here the just shall
live how by faith now if you are in
Christ where's Christ as I said earlier
on the right hand of God now how is
Christ in us through the Holy Spirit
angels are not filled with the Holy
Spirit Jesus does not dwell in
angels He dwells in
US listen to John 14 from: 16 and I will
pray the father well find it find it so
you can with me and he shall give you
another comforter that he may abide with
you forever even the spirit of Truth
whom the world cannot receive because
they seeth him not neither knoweth him
but you know him for he dwelleth with
you you have't it's not under the screen
yet he dwelleth with you and shall be in
you the Holy Ghost does not inhabit the
angels He indwells us as a matter of
fact I'll tell you something else even
more dramatic
perhaps Jesus had 12 disciples did he
travel with them yes or no did they
travel in the boat with him yes or no
did they sleep on the ground with him
yes did they eat with him yes they
touched him yes but you and I are closer
to Christ now than they
were because they were Christ was with
them he was not in them
Christ was with them he was not in
them when the Holy Ghost came Christ now
was in them but during the three and a
half years when they walked with Christ
physically he was not in them in that
sense you and I today through faith in
Christ are closer to him than the Angels
than the disciples were while Christ was
with them but hold on to your seats I'll
tell you something
else tell me if you're
ready we through the indwelling spirit
of Christ are closer to Christ now than
Adam was before he
sinned you're looking at me as though I
need
medication I don't take
medication let me say it
again through the indwelling spirit and
the spirit is called both the spirit of
God and the spirit of
Christ and since the fullness of the
godhead dwells in Christ when his Spirit
comes the spirit brings that
fullness we are closer to Christ now
when we surrender to him than Adam was
before Adam sinned in other words the
only time we'll be closer is when he
actually comes
don't you want
that don't you want that for your
children a place right next to
God by faith that's where you and I are
right now and so Ephesians says verse 6
and have raised us up together of
chapter 2 and have made us sit together
in Heavenly places in Christ Jesus
Ephesians 2:3 blessed be the God and
father of our Lord Jesus Christ who ha
blessed us with all spiritual blessings
in Christ in Heavenly places in Christ
Jesus we need to understand what it
means the blessings that come from being
in Christ and Christ in us let Christ
himself explain the nature of the Union
let's go back to John 17 we read from
verse 9
we read several verses this is Christ
praying and the disciples are listening
to him as he prays Judas is gone he left
in John 13 when Christ said that thou
doest do quickly do you have John 17 we
read from verse 9 this is a remarkable
verse verse 9 read with me I pray for
them meaning the disciples keep reading
I pray not for the world stop
I am not praying for the world now says
Christ I am praying for these 11
men isn't that something to have the
Creator look at the entire world and
only pray for
you I pray for them I pray not for the
world but for them which thou Hast given
me for they thine verse 10 and all mine
are thine and thine are mine and I am
glorified in them and now I'm no more in
the world but the are in the world and I
come to thee Holy Father keep through
thy known name Those whom thou Hast
given me that they may be one
how as we
are while I was with them in the world I
kept them in thy name those that thou
gavest me I have kept and none of them
is lost but the son of predition that
the scripture might be fulfilled and now
come I to thee and these things I speak
in the world that they might have my joy
fulfilled in themselves have given them
Thy word and the world hath hated them
because they are not of the world even
as I am not of the world I pray not that
thou sh take them out of the world but
that thou sh keep them from the evil
they are not of the world even as I am
not of the world sanctify them through
thy truth Thy word is TR as thou has
sent me into the world even so have I
also sent them into the world and and
for their sakes I sanctify myself but
look at 17 sanctify them how through thy
truth how do you think Christ was
Sanctified same Truth for their sakes I
sanctify myself that they also might be
Sanctified through the truth now what
does this have to do with you read verse
20 nice and Loud neither pray I for
these alone but for them also which
Shall Believe on me through their word
who is that us with a capital u or
however you spell Us in Corby
us neither pray I for these alone but
for them also which Shall Believe on me
through their word which means the
prayer he offered 200 years ago covers
you that's one of the most lifeless
amens I've ever
heard I said that prayer covers
you keep reading verse 21 that they all
may be one
how as thou father art in me and I in
thee that there also may be one in us
and that the world may believe that thou
has sent me and the glory which thou
givest me I have given them that they
may be one even as we were one we read
that in verse 11 verse 21 verse
22 i in them and thou in me that they
may be made perfect in one that the
world may know that thou has sent me and
has loved them as thou Hast loved me ah
you didn't get that
Jesus says love them how the way you
love
me love them the way you love
me oh boy which means there are some
people on the Earth God loves more than
others you didn't hear me because it
strikes a contrary note to what you're
custom thinking that God loves everyone
the same
way no he doesn't he loves some more
than he loves
others the desire of AES page 524
paragraph 1 listen carefully the Desire
of Ages page 524 paragraph 1 listen to
Ellen
White the Savior blessed all who sought
his help he loves all the Human
family but to some he's Bound by
peculiarly tender associations his heart
was knit by a strong bond of affection
to the family at Bethany Mary Martha and
Lazarus and for one of them his most
wonderful work was wrought in other
words Christ reserved his most powerful
miracle for the family closest to him
and Christ is the same yesterday today
and forever get close to him he may
Reserve blessings for you he gives to
nobody
else go back to verse 21 and 22 let's
see the closeness God desires to have
with us let's read from 20 neither pray
I for these alone but for them also
which Shall Believe on me through their
word that they all may be one as thou
father art in me and I in thee that they
also may be one in us so when you are in
Christ you're
also in the father notice I in them 23
and thou in me is all you take some
flour some sugar whatever some sawdust
and you make
something all mixed up and you bake it
so you have Jesus and the father and you
all mixed
up and then Jesus tells the father
love them as much as you love me do you
understand those words Jesus is praying
to the father now we know if Jesus prays
to the Father the father will
answer love them as much as you love me
but he says that again towards the end
of that
chapter go to verse 26
and I have declared unto them thy
name read with me and will declare it
come on that the love where with thou
has loved me may be in them and I the
same may you love me put that love in
them Jesus is the
creator of Heaven and Earth he's the
commander of the angels He is equal with
the
father yet the father loves us as much
as he loves
Jesus the Angels don't share that
love how will you and I repair That Kind
of Love by
smoking by
drinking getting into
fight sleeping
[Music]
around cheating
lying how will we pay that love you know
what the Bible says we love him because
come on he first loved us the reason why
we don't love him we don't understand
his first love when we understand it our
response is love for him because we're
told by ELO love begets
Love Actually psychologists tell you if
you want a favor from someone do a favor
first and it sets the person up to do
one for you do a favor first
then ask the person for one the person
finds it difficult to say no it can be a
form of manipulation so that's not what
I'm promoting I'm simply saying we love
him
because he first loved
us what have I told you
today this world is a pit
stop are you with me when you drive the
highway United States we have rest stops
you have them in Britain rest stops you
pull over there's a store bathroom get
gas and the pit then you move on the pit
stop is not your final
destination you gas up and you
go this world is a pit
stop and so we go to church we work we
do all of that our destination is the
kingdom of
God let me show you something else about
how much God thinks of us go to
Revelation
21 Revelation 21
let's read from verse
one Revelation written by
John the youngest of the 12 disciples
the one closest to Christ he wrote the
Gospel of John 1 John 2 John third John
and Revelation read with me and I saw a
new Heaven and a new Earth for the first
Heaven and the first Earth were passed
away and there was no more sea and I
John saw what the holy city New
Jerusalem coming down from God out of
Heaven prepared as a bride a dawn for a
husband read verse three carefully now
and I heard a great voice where Out of
Heaven saying what behold the Tabernacle
of God come on is with
man he ah he will do what yeah which
means when this Earth is established
brand new the headquarters of the
universe is put on this Earth
this Earth becomes number 10 Downing
Street the only place where sin
occurred that's
love there are planets where people
never sinned God puts his throne right
here because Jesus will identify more
closely with us former Sinners than with
any other created being in the universe
now how do you understand that you would
think he would distance himself to save
himself some
embarrassment but
no let's go to Luke 24 let's take
another look at the tremendous blessings
then I'll release you it's what time is
it somebody tell me the time 20 P
what oh that's all well I shouldn't say
that's all I shouldn't say that sounds
threatening I didn't mean it that way
okay I'll release you shortly Don't
Panic what book did I say what chapter
24 let's read from verse 36 Father in
heaven continue to be with me please and
let your word lift the spirits of your
people in Jesus name I pray amen read
with me and as they thus spake Jesus
himself stood in the midst of them and
said unto them what peace be unto you
but they were terrified and AF frighted
and supposed they had seen a spirit
stop Christ is not a ghost
he did not arise from the grave as a
spirit they thought he was a spirit that
wasn't the only time in Luke Matthew 14
when he walked on the water they cried
out for fear they thought it was a
spirit it's a terrible thing when a
Flesh and Bones Christ is regarded as a
spirit and he said unto them why are you
troubled and why do thoughts arise in
your heart behold my hands and my feet
that it is I myself in the greatek
that's intensive no mistake I myself now
handle me and see for the spirit hath
not Flesh and Bones as ye see me have
why did Jesus say behold my hands and my
feet the wounds of the crucifixion he
came from the grave with the wounds even
though he came with a different
body he had a glorified body which we
will have when we rise from the grave or
we translated but he keeps the
wounds he will keep the them for how
long
forever what wounds will you and I have
in the new world
none something's not right about that
arrangement from a human standpoint
something's not right that the innocent
Christ has the
marks guilty
man blem unblemish skin not a pimple not
one
someone perhaps coming from another
galaxy not knowing the story of
redemption will look at Christ and look
at me and say what did he
do and I'll have to say quickly no he
did nothing it's
me but he took my
suffering if that doesn't break the
heart I don't know what
will he carries the
marks he carries
Humanity the marks where are they his
hand
his feet his side his
brow ours no scratches no surgical
wounds
nothing he will carry that
forever here's something I love to talk
about all the time I mention this is so
astonishing something else will continue
forever in the
godhead there will be be a human being
in the godhead there is one now that's
Christ before he came and be uh human
and went back they were just Spirit
father Spirit son Spirit holy
ghost in order to save us the godhead
underwent a change and the change is
permanent so now the godhead has a human
being in it which is Christ who's also
God but that human being is scred so the
godhead has
scars to save people who don't even like
God the godhead has a scarred
member we don't like to take the blame
for what others do we're quick to say
not me even when we're guilty not
me Jesus says
me the angel said but she did it now she
confessed
me he committed murder
me he ripped
me for all
eternity my brothers and my
sisters let me conclude by telling you
Christ is coming
back he's coming back for a people ready
for him some Churches teach when he
comes there will be a probationary time
to convert no let me show you if you
think from the Bible go to Leviticus 1
we read from verse one from Leviticus
164 sorry reading verse 4 here is the
description of Aaron when he's
ministering in a holy Place Aaron
Leviticus
16:4 then we go to Revelation 14 and
read verse
14 you have Leviticus book number three
the key word in Leviticus is
Holiness it appear occurs 93 times in
The Book of Leviticus the next closest
book is Exodus with 55 times Ezekiel I
think has 53 or something like that but
Holiness is the theme of Leviticus
Holiness chapter 16:4 read with me and
he shall put on what the holy Len court
and he shall have the linen Bridges upon
his flesh and shall be girded with the
linen giren and with the linen might
shall he be attired These Are Holy
garments therefore he shall wash his
flesh in water and so put them on the
miter was a head thing he wore are you
with me as a priest go to Revelation
14 Revelation
14 only Adventists can explain
Revelation and I'm not bragging I'm
speaking the fact only seven of the
Adventists can explain let me add
another book Daniel and
Revelation Revelation 14
read verse 14 with me and I look and
behold what one like to the son one on a
cloud what does he have in his
head a crown what does he have in his
hand a sickle
now the word sickle occurs
about 10 or 11 times in the entire
Bible about six of those
times it occurs in the New Testament
and most of those occurrences are in
Revelation 14 a
sickle every place in the Bible where
the word sickle is used a harvest is
suggested every single place Joel chter
3: 13 put ye in the sickle for the
Harvest is ripe when the fruit is
brought forth immediately he put it in
the sickle Mark 4:29
and3 Christ now is
seen a crown on his head
and a sickle in his hand not a
sensor
interceding a sickle to reap a
harvest now why does he come with a
sickle and not a sensor a sense is
useless let me tell you why look at
verse 15 of Revelation 14 read nice and
loud and another angel came out of the
temple crying with a loud voice to him
that sat on the cloud thrust in thy
sickle and reap for the time has come
for thee to reap for the Harvest of the
Earth Earth is ripe
ripe when something is ripe what do you
do you pick it thank you sister from the
country you pick
it the Harvest of the earth is ripe
that's one
Harvest go to verse
17 read for me and another angel came
out of the temple which is in heaven
you're also having a sharp CLE verse 14
verse 18 another angel came out of thee
keep reading crying with a loud cry to
him that heard the Shar sickle saying
thirst an th sickle and gather the the
vine of the Earth for her grapes are
fully ripe now we have two harvests both
ripe so the the point of intercession is
useless they are both right the first
harvest is the Harvest of the saved the
second one goes into the wine press of
the wrath of God that's the Harvest of
the
Lost Christ comes to reap he'll separate
the wheat from the chaff the sheep from
the
goats not to show
Mercy you see when he leaves the
Heavenly Court he takes off his Priestly
robes takes off the miter puts on a
crown comes back as a
conqueror and so churches who tell you
when Christ comes back there's an
opportunity to repent they are preparing
you for
Destruction the time to repent is now
are you following
me and so Christ is coming for people
who are
ripe for him to save them he's coming
for those ripe against him to destroy
them both har the only similar thing
between the lost and the saved is that
both are right I am fully for God I am
fully against God what brings the world
to that condition The Three Angels
messages only seven of
Adventists preach
that that's our
calling I often say and always say it is
very good for the church to give out
clothes and blankets and food
but there are other organizations that
do that are you with me what is there no
organization other organization does
that we alone can do preach the three
that's our priority yes we give out food
and blanket yes but this church was not
raised up to be a social services
organization it was raised up to prepare
people to evacuate the
Earth because destruction is coming are
you with me
evacuate this
Earth when the wildfires in the Western
United States the police come and they
Evacuate the town everybody is the fire
is
coming if uh whatever flood they
Evacuate the town a blizzard they
evacuate get out trouble is
coming this world is
dying and Christ is coming to get us off
the sinking
shap and then he build a brand new one
which will never sink sail through
eternity and another eternity and
another
eternity forever now you and I cannot
understand forever because people die
all the time you go to school after four
years you're done there's a beginning
and an end the life to come will have no
end which leads me to another sacrifice
Christ made when he
died here is a God
an eternal God we do not know how long
Father Son and Holy Ghost existed before
they decided to create we don't
know but Christ is eternal he has always
been there now he subjects himself to
the experience of
[Music]
ending that's said asking a turtle to
fly or an eagle to
crawl he subjected himself to the
experience
of an
end in the
grave but he did that to save
you when a person rejects all that I
said you can understand why the Bible
says how shall we escape if we neglect
so great
salvation let me make one more
recommendation for you memorize some
Bible
verses have them on the job have have
them on the tube have them on the
playground have them wherever bring them
up say them think about them and be
benefit benefited by the power the word
of God releases remember the entire
universe was made by and God said keep
that power with you here ELO white
writes education page 126 paragraph 4
the cre cretive energy that called the
worlds into existence is in the word of
God this word imparts power it begets
life every command is a promise accepted
by the will received into the soul it
brings with it the life of the infinite
one who is that God himself it
transforms the nature and recreates the
soul in the image of
God Psalm
138:2 thou H has magnified Thy Word
above all thy name the new world is
Promised in the
word deliverance from this Earth promise
in the word on the right hand of Christ
promise in the word developing a
Christlike character promise in the word
victory over Satan promis in the word
when you receive the word that's when
you receive the reality how many of you
want to place in God's kingdom when he
comes can I see your hand do you mean
that stand up with
me has the sun
set the sun has set so we are in secular
time what does that mean do you feel as
though you've been released from holy
time is this a jailbreak from
righteousness are you still holy then
should you watch what you do tonight
come on I can't did you get laryngitis
all of a sudden should you watch what
you do tonight why because we're
holy Holiness doesn't
cease we thank God for the holy day but
the sun did not set on your Holiness
whatever you do tonight I am a holy
person I'm going to pray before I do
anyone has a prayer
request raise your hand and tell me
me are you actually telling God but I'm
listening yes my
sister pray for your family all right
Jesus has a family and you included in
it El said the family in heaven and the
family on Earth are one the church in
heaven the church on Earth are one she
doesn't mean the whole earth is one with
Heaven those who accept Christ and
Believe on him are one with the Heavenly
family someone else uh prayer request
yes please pray for my brother who's
alcoholic your brother an alcoholic okay
please all right right back there
sister can you please pray for my sister
she has been recently diagnosed with
skin cancer oh okay all right okay yes
right
here I pray God helps us be living
Salmons you do what God help us be
living
Sammons how us to be living Ser oh yes
yes okay all right my brother well over
here my lovely sister to the right maybe
you need two
microphones it's your okay it's all
right uh someone else can grab a mic and
run around please pray for my friend um
friend she's never been in church it's
the first time she's handled a Bible
that I've given her okay but she's in
search of the truth and she's in search
for understanding okay all right
okay my brother right
here uh pray for me uh I've been doing a
Bible study with the Pentecostal pastors
mhm which I did with you more than 5
years ago and for the first time this
week MH they were becoming receptive to
the truth yes so may you pray that as
you they've now requested for more Bible
studies we're doing one every week they
said starting this week we need two and
they've asked now for the Sabbath
they've now believed the Lord okay
praise God for that mhm we have a hand
right in front of my brother pastor
mik um I want to pray for a girl in my
school who is continuous pray for what a
girl at my school a girl at your school
she is continuously lying and I would
just want to pray that she stops okay
all right thank you very much God bless
you for being an intercessor on her
behalf somebody else oh we have a hand
on the left is there somebody else who
can use a mic just you don't have my
sister running to exhaustion here
yes okay pray for my family my children
please all right sister your family your
children M right back there there's a
[Music]
hand please pray for my son spiritual
life he does not believe in Christ so
just how is please he's 27 and going to
other struggles all right 27 yeah all
right we'll what's his
name who
russan
rashan
Rashon she's saying Vashon V A
fashon fashon all right my
apologies anybody else yes we have some
hands over there isn't there a second
person with a mic um oh okay I'm iting
um prayer for a friend of mine who was
once a 7 Adventist but um she has left
the church okay um and she's saying that
Jesus um the law was fulfilled at the
cross so she doesn't need to okay to so
please um pray for her and also for
healing for a young friend of ours
sitting behind me here um he has
challenges um Health um medical wise so
yeah all right thank you I'm kindly
asking that you pray for kage 7th
Adventist Church we've been going
through a series of grief we lost a
teenager just recently and soon after
that we lost one of our elderly ladies
so I'm just asking that you pray that
from this time onwards there should be
light and there should be joy and give
us hope to keep on holding on because
it's been a very difficult time for us
all right okay uh i' to the right for
Lista my friend
Lista can we pray for my friend Lista
Lista yes all right she used to attend
an Adventist Church as a child but she's
having a real struggle to accept that
God's Sabbath is Saturday okay all right
okay all right
okay uh someone over here yes can I ask
you to please pray for my parents
relation sh your what my parents
relationship your parents relationship
okay all right thank you my lovely
sister uh where oh yes for me that this
word we have heard lives in okay yes yes
yes you hear the word we act on it my
brother back there there are several
hands and I have one over here against
the wall uh this side is for the sister
uh this side is for
you okay I like to pray for peace and
like for healing after me and my family
lost like a daughter a sister and a
cousin as well okay somebody else yeah
okay um can you kindly pray for a
colleague of mine
she oh yes a colleague of mine she was
deeply um involved in
Hinduism and um now she has found Christ
but because of how deep she was she's
having nightmares and all sorts can we
just pray for her the enemy does not
release people easily but Christ will
release her all right uh where are we
right here um a prayer for
Thanksgiving uh we asked for prayer for
you to pray for my sister last week she
was going for a surgery the surgery was
successful on Wednesday when is she
going for the surgery she went for the
oh she went and it was successful God we
thank God yes indeed mhm
uh I would like to to pray for my
brother your brother um he doesn't
believe he does believe but he hasn't
opened the Bible since we've given him
one he's getting all these inspirational
thoughts and sayings and meanings but he
wouldn't say where they're coming from
okay uh your brother what's his name
Oliver Oliver okay thank you uh where
yes um just to pray for um uh my
colleagues uh brother he used to be
brother yes uh or friend's brother so he
used to be an Adventist uh and he's
slowly um backsliding so just to pray
for him young as well so just in church
yes where oh we have okay yes sister
yeah um requesting prayers for my sister
who um she's not Adventist uh but she
loves the Lord I'm praying that the Lord
will open the eyes of her understanding
she is more of the doctrine they are
teaching is more of
spiritualism rather than that says the
Lord so I'm praying that the Lord will
open her spiritual heart okay okay when
you pray for people who are in spiritual
problems remind God that he said he's
not willing that any should perish 2
Peter 3:9 When you pray say father you
said in 1 Timothy 2:4 you will have all
people to be saved and to come under the
knowledge of the truth always pray using
God's word he will never deny his word
it's not a means of uh manipulation it
is simply using God's word he will
always stand behind his
word yes um could we have a prayer for
all the students going into exam season
and with like cour Works coming up when
does the exam season begin well for
University students some of us have like
um exams in January throughout January
okay all right now that you mention for
all students listen to these words
Christ object lessons page 125 paragraph
3 if the follower of Christ will believe
his word and practice it there is no
science in the natural world he will not
be able to grasp and appreciate I to say
you obey God and he will open your brain
to understand any science if the
follower of Christ will believe his word
and practice it there is no science in
the natural world he will not be able to
grow grasp and appreciate grasp mean I
understand it appreciate means see in
the light of God yes um pray for my
brother he's in his 40s and he's had um
two serious Strokes okay all right yeah
that is serious right over here uh
please pray for my family as we navigate
challenges with our stay here in the UK
with your what stay our right to live
here in the UK okay yes all right
legally you mean residence okay all
right yes uh I have a
colleague and uh I've been having uh
Bible study or studying the Bible with
him MH he is gay mhm he's married MH to
another man mhm and they have adopted
two children okay he tells me that he's
a Christian he believes in God mhm so
I've been discussing with him and I told
him because he told me that he has read
the Bible so many times and ask him you
know the verses that I can remember uh
asking him if he has come across that
and he said uh I have but I still have a
problem okay so he says he has got a
fear because he's he say he calls him my
husband okay all right does not allow me
to go to church okay but if God speaks
to meh because I believe that he's
working in me okay then I will tell him
I have to live this lifestyle okay so if
you can pray for him that God intervenes
in his heart all right I also have two
nephews who are at University and they
asked me to pray for them to have a
relationship with God okay they are both
19 okay thank you thank you thank
you anyone yes yeah could you pray for
my mom recently she's not been feeling
well your mother yeah okay all
right let me is that it hello oh yes yes
I'm soliciting prayer for my little
sister in Jamaica she's always been sick
from age 11 now she's
um the thing is that because it's I
think it's spiritual cuz every time she
goes to the doctor they can't find
what's wrong with her and it even
stopped her from going to school MH um
so now she's going through another
challenge but she always hold on to
faith in God so I'm just asking for
complete healing so she can get her life
restored um to get back into living okay
all
right okay uh may I ask for prayer for a
colleague she's just retired from
nursing and she's been diagnosed with
Buel cancer and it's metastasized to her
okay sorry it's very serious all right
any yes yeah I just have one for my
siblings for their health and
wholeness your siblings for their health
and and whole like spiritual all right
okay okay I want to inconvenience you
could you kneel with me
please Father in heaven
I come to youday God as the voice of
your
people you've heard all the prayer
requests Jesus said or the angel told
Mary in Luke
137 for with God nothing shall be
impossible the Bible tells us in Psalm
103:3 speaking of God who forgiveth all
our iniquities
who Health all our
diseases father you through Christ asked
Abraham in Genesis
18:14 is anything too hard for the
Lord the answer is
no Jesus at your direction said come
onto me all ye that labor and a heavy
laden I will give you
rest the Holy Ghost told Peter to write
first Peter
57 casting all your cares upon Him for
he carth for
you Father in
Heaven I present to you now every single
request that was mentioned and there are
probably some too private to be
mentioned publicly look at them as well
now God first of all if during this
afternoon session we've sinned against
you forgive us if I said anything I
should not have said forgive me
God and now as a merciful
god pay individual attention to every
case father deal with each case as if
that's the only thing occupying your
attention show as much Mercy as you
will heal
father
restore
save reclaim and encourage defend lift
up bless
provide Inspire and
encourage dear God your servant tells us
Christ healed everyone who came to
Him Father in Heaven as you see fit
place your healing hand on the sick
whether you deliver them immediately or
over a period of time the miracle is the
same
heal broken families father reunite
divided spouses God give direction to
those who have strayed from your Remnant
Church bring them
back as you said in Jeremiah 3:12 go and
Proclaim these words to the words of
North and say return backsliding Israel
and I will not cause my anger to fall
upon you bring back those who strayed
away
father while this was not mentioned as a
problem there may be some who do not
make time for your
word the very healing people desire is
through the word Jesus raised the dead
through the word he steal a storm
through the word he resisted Satan
through the word it is all through the
word de
God and so I plead with you father I
offer know I give no commands I demand
nothing I just appeal to
you if you could send Christ to die for
us surely you can provide some healing
restoration Clarity of mind again I ask
you God pay attention to every single
case that was mentioned individual
attention father and work so powerfully
that the person will know only God could
have done what happened thank you for
the Revival thank you for those who came
let us leave this place different people
people father growing from this point
forward forward forward and
upward work through us to bring others
to
Christ bless every family de god father
I present to you a very special group of
people Those Who provided food for your
servant bless them God let their houses
be storehouses of Plenty let them want
for nothing father provide food shelter
and clothing for them because in doing
it for me they did it for you because I
am the least of your disciples protect
their children from harm from sickness
heal whatever family problems they have
thank you for their kindness to me bless
the Corby Church the Catherine church
the Willing brother church if members
need to forgive let them forgive each
other their God let them what's
necessary that the spirit may have his
way bless the
pastor father give that man the wisdom
of Solomon that he may guide your people
right because pastoral leadership is
burdensome work Moses asked you to kill
him it became so heavy for him dear God
find the sweetest blessing in your
Storehouse and put it on the children
that they may grow up to love Jesus and
remember made faithful to his
church bless the conference in which
this church is bless the union father
bless every level level of
administration under which this these
churches fall and father when you come
save every one of them without losing
one please in the name of Jesus Christ I
pray let God's people say amen and amen
God bless you my friends thank you for
the joy of fellowshipping with you
wherever you are if I come across your
mind please say to God father put your
words in that man's mouth